-Hey, hey!
I want to remind everybody,
"5 More Sleeps"
the animated special...
[ Cheers and applause ]
"5 More Sleeps 'Til Christmas"
airs next Friday, December 23rd,
at 8:30 p.m.,
after "The Grinch" on NBC.
Check it out, get cozy
with your family.
Cozy up around the tree,
enjoy "5 More Sleeps."
And if you want a little
something before then,
I went out under
the Rockefeller Center
Christmas tree earlier tonight
and I videotaped myself
reading the book.
Or videoed myself.
I guess I didn't videotape it.
-Sure.
-I videoed myself
reading the book
in virtual reality 360.
So if you have the YouTube app,
if you have a VR headset,
if you have an Oculus,
go search for Jimmy Fallon's
"5 More Sleeps."
You'll see it.
You look at the tree.
You can look at me.
It's pretty bizarre. It's fun.
It's not the metaverse,
but it's New York City.
That's all.
[ Cheers and applause ]